[Music]
at a time when plenty of former steelers
are criticizing quarterback ben
rothsberger juju smith schuster team mvp
for the 2018 season if you haven't heard
goes to twitter and says i was so
blessed to enter the league and play
with the hall of fame quarterback as a
20 year old ben has taught me so much
he's a true leader and i can't wait to
rock with my guy this season
later
antonio brown had this to say without
singling out juju smith schuster or
anyone else do not listen to any nfl
player who haven't got paid yet they
will do and say anything to make sure
they're going to get paid even if it's
compromising integrity or anything sad
but true i think that was a message to
juju smith schuster and to anyone who
may want to put stock in smith
schuster's praise of ben roethlisberger
obviously antonio brown one of the
former steelers very critical of ben
roethlisberger and we know that's real
we know that's a thing drew rosenhouse
told us that earlier in the week that's
an open book
and look i i when i saw the smith
schuster tweet i'm thinking like he's
he's sucking up to his quarterback that
that that is as old as football itself
since the invention of the forward pass
receivers have been sucking up to the
guys who throw them yeah that's right i
mean you know again listen antonio
brown's point it's real i mean to to a
degree i'm gonna say it doesn't like
hold true to every player in the history
of football i mean hey larry fitzgerald
and peyton manning and people like that
they said things before they got paid
and after and and yes it did well yeah
it just it didn't matter but they never
you know i guess the big thing i was
saying is juju smith schuster could be
speaking from the heart here i mean
honestly hey juju smith schuster was the
offensive mvp for the pittsburgh
steelers and big moments throughout the
year last year juju was the favorite of
antonio i mean of ben roethlisberger so
you know again yeah is he kissing up to
the quarterback a little of course he is
he wants the ball he wants the guy to
like him he wants the offense to be
orchestrated around him it doesn't mean
he's just doing it because he hasn't got
paid yet and he wants to get paid before
he speaks out and talks about what a
what an ass ben ralph's burger is well
there's a certain amount of politician
that you have to be if you're going to
be a receiver when you were a
quarterback right you had to deal with
that
you have players vying for your
attention and affection so when you have
the discretion yes to go from this guy
to this guy to this guy you're going to
choose to let go of the ball with the
guy that you like with the guy that you
trust with the guy that you think has
your back and and there is that there is
human element that factors into it there
is there's no question about that now
this is an element here where you know
who the hell else is he gonna throw to
anyways on the roster right now right so
juju is in the position of power he
doesn't really even need to say this
because he's going to be the go-to guy
there's no if ands or buts about it he's
the number one i don't know who they're
going to draft well maybe they'd be
antonio brown antonio brown was the guy
before junior came along okay i get you
that's a good point too but i mean as
he's sitting here right now we know he's
the number one guy for the pittsburgh
steelers then he was the offense mvp for
the football team so uh
again but to you to what you're saying
yes i mean receivers are like that they
want to make the quarterbacks happy but
at the same time the quarterback knows
who the talented guy is nobody joey
galloway didn't need to kiss my butt for
me to throw him the ball after being at
practice with him on a daily basis i
went damn this guy's really fast and
he's always open when in doubt i'm gonna
throw it to number 84 joey galloway
because we had all rule too when he went
deep
if he's even
finish it if he's even he's what he's
leaving
okay yeah that's not easy because when
you threw the ball in the air to special
receivers like a juju or antonio brown
if it was even between him and the db i
understand that
if he's even he's late he's even because
when the ball in the air those when he
got the gear i'm leaving in a little bit
actually we got to finish the show
because i got a flight to catch
and i'm doing my best to passive
aggressively make you miss your friend
thank you oh i think we read it i need i
think we need to redo this song
good all right so um look i i look at it
this way juju smith schuster put his
nose in a certain part of ben
roethlisberger's anatomy okay it worked
and he's going to leave it there there's
no reason to move it now well and why
does antonio brown have to say it i mean
what what does he feel so that's a great
point
stay out of it tony you're not on the
team anymore what does he care anymore
like let it go gear done close the
yearbook let it go
let it go you don't play there anymore i
didn't know that song was an option yeah
it is well when i sing my voice is so
special i i reach other levels but yeah
i just don't understand why he has to
comment about every little thing
pittsburgh right now well i i think that
he is still hurt by a little bit right
yeah and and he is bitter
juju smith schuster is named the team
mvp and even though he wanted out there
was there was still a sense that they
didn't want him
and you want to be able to dictate your
terms and you want your team to still
want you and i think he felt unwanted
that was part of why he wanted to get
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports